Hi ihr Lieben!
Ich zeig euch heute wie ihr ganz einfach und schnell fluffige amerikanische Pancakes hinbekommt.
Wir hatten jetzt Crêpes und Pfannkuchen und da hab ich mir gedacht: Das Trio muss komplett sein
indem wir jetzt einfach Pancakes machen!
Und ich zeig euch das Ganze jetzt Schritt für Schritt.
Ich benutz heute die Küchenmaschine, natürlich könnt ihr auch euer Handrührgerät benutzen,
dann dauert's halt nur ein paar Minuten länger beim Aufschlagen.
Und wichtig bei Pancakes ist, dass wir jetzt die Eier getrennt voneinander verarbeiten.
Also erstmal das Eiweiß in die Rührschüssel geben, da kommt eine ordentliche Prise Salz dazu.
Dann schlage ich das so ungefähr 30sek damit's so ein bisschen schaumig und dick wird
und dann kommt der Zucker dazu und wird zu einer Baisermasse geschlagen,
also komplett steif geschlagen.
So, nach 2min wenn ihr die Eier richtig schön sauber getrennt habt und kein fettiges Eigelb mehr
in der Eiweißmasse ist, habt ihr eine richtig schön Baisermasse -
Moment, es wird kurz laut! So!
So, nichts verschwenden. So sieht's aus.
Die kommt ganz kurz zur Seite. Die darf nicht zu lange stehen weil sie sonst einsinkt,
deshalb machen wir jetzt direkt weiter.
Aber ich spüle jetzt nicht diesen Schneebesen, ich spar mir diesen Schritt,
geb da jetzt die andere Rührschüssel drauf und dann wird das Eigelb
zusammen mit Vanilleextrakt auch so 2-3min richtig schön cremig geschlagen und dann geht's weiter.
So, danach einmal Buttermilch hinzugeben, kurz verrühren lassen
und anschließend einmal die trockenen Zutaten vorab verrühren.
Das heißt: Mehl mit Backpulver und Natron verrühren und zur Masse sieben.
Und das hab ich jetzt hier schon erledigt.
So und das rühre ich jetzt auch nochmal ganz kurz mit ein.
Und falls ihr euch jetzt wundert: "Wo sind denn hier die ganz genauen Mengenangaben?"
Die findet ihr immer unter dem Videotitel in der Videobeschreibung, da habt ihr's nämlich ganz genau.
So, das rühre ich jetzt ganz kurz mit ein und danach mit ganz viel Liebe die Baisermasse unterheben.
So, jetzt geht's ans Ausbacken. Der Teig ist ja jetzt fertig, ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass wenn er ungefähr 10min ruht, dass er dann einfach - also dass die Pancakes dann perfekt werden.
Nur so als Tipp nebenbei!
Ich nehm immer gerne Kokosfett zum Ausbacken von Pancakes, geschmacklich sind die dann einfach top
und ich hab auch das Gefühl, dass die von der Oberfläche her einfach besser werden.
Alternativen wären jetzt z.B. Rapsöl oder Sonnenblumenöl
aber auf keinen Fall Olivenöl oder sowas.
So, da hab ich jetzt die beschichtete Pfanne mit eingefettet.
Und was ich noch mache damit sie wirklich perfekt werden - das Auge isst natürlich mit! -
ich nehme mir meinen Mini-Tortenring. Als Alternative könntet ihr jetzt einen Ausstecher nehmen,
am besten soll der auch relativ hoch sein damit er nicht an der Oberfläche -
also damit er hier oben nicht so heiß wird und ihr ihn in Ruhe anfassen könnt.
Einmal ein bisschen einfetten mit Kokosfett. Und jetzt, damit die auch immer gleich hoch werden,
nehme ich mir hier meinen Eisportionierer, gehe da rein
und dann verteile ich das noch so ein bisschen und backe die von beiden Seiten aus.
So, jetzt sind die nächsten 2 fertig und ich backe jetzt hier einfach fröhlich vor mich hin
und lasse euch gehen! Ihr müsst ja jetzt hier nicht warten, ne?
Also ihr seht gleich die schönen Endszenen, die der Hamza macht
und dann könnt ihr das mit Ahornsirup oder mit Honig oder mit Nutella,
mit was auch immer ihr möchtet könnt ihr das genießen.
Was auch super passt sind frische Früchte.
Aber ich wollte euch vorher noch den Tipp geben: natürlich müsst ihr selber gucken,
wie lange das zum Ausbacken braucht. Jeder Ofen - ach, jeder Ofen! - jeder Herd ist anders,
jede Pfanne ist anders. Bei mir war's so: Ich hab 9 Stufen und ich schwanke immer
zwischen Stufe 4 und 5, also mittlere Hitze. Und dann braucht es von jeder Seite
so ungefähr 3 bis maximal 4min.
Müsst ihr einfach mal schauen und dann gelingt euch das 100%, ich gebe euch die...?
(H: Kiki-Garantie!)
Die Kiki-Garantie, dass ihr fluffige Pancakes
hinbekommen werdet mit diesem Rezept!
Also ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen und ich freue mich über eure Fotos!
Taggt mich gerne auf Instagram, dann kann ich sie reposten, mir angucken...
Darüber freue ich mich immer wirklich sehr!
Und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Video!
Und abonniert! Abonnieren nicht vergessen!
Bis dann, Tschüss!